>>> PERHAPS IT WAS THE MAYOR OF
KYIV, KLITSCHKO, WHO SAID IT
RIGHT ABOUT THE CLAIM RUSSIAN
FORCES ARE ONLY HITTING MILITARY
TARGETS IN UKRAINE.
>> THEY DESTROYED, THEY KILLED
CHILDREN, WOMEN, CIVILIANS, FOR
WHAT REASON?
>> PUTIN SAYS HE'S ONLY
TARGETING MILITARY TARGETS.
>> BULLSHIT, SORRY.
>> THE MAYOR CAN SEE THROUGH
PUTIN'S LIES AND SO CAN WE.
THIS VIDEO SHOWS A GRIEVING MAN
ON HIS KNEES CRYING OVER THE
BODY OF HIS DEAD MOTHER OUTSIDE
OF A BOMBED OUT KYIV APARTMENT
BUILDING.
HIS AGONY IS UKRAINE'S AGONY.
WE'VE HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT THE
SIEGE IN MARIUPOL WHERE A
THEATER USED AS A BOMB SHELTER
WAS LEVELED BY RUSSIAN STRIKES.
THE RUSSIANS WERE WARNED IN
ADVANCE THAT CHILDREN WERE
INSIDE, THE WORD CHILDREN
SPELLED OUT TO NOTIFY THE
RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIANS SLAUGHTERED THEM
ANYWAY.
OTHER REPORTS FROM MARIUPOL ARE
EQUALLY HORRIFYING, THIS WEEKEND
A LOCAL CITY COUNCIL SAYS
RUSSIAN STRIKES DESTROYED A
SCHOOL WHERE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
WERE TAKING SHELTER.
THE CITY COUNCIL ALSO SAYS
THOUSANDS OF ITS RESIDENTS HAVE
BEEN FORCIBLY TAKEN TO REMOTE
CITIES IN RUSSIA.
THE MAYOR COMPARED THE RUSSIANS'
ACTIONS TO THOSE OF THE NAZIS IN
WORLD WAR II.
THE RUSSIANS ARE BEGINNING TO
TARGET PARTS OF WESTERN UKRAINE
LIKE THE CITY OF LVIV WHERE
PEOPLE LINED UP EMPTY STROLLERS
TO SYMBOLIZE THE CHILDREN KILLED
IN PUTIN'S WAR.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO SHIELD
THEIR INNOCENT CHILDREN FROM THE
RUSSIANS.
THEY'RE HIDING THEIR BABIES
UNDERGROUND FROM PUTIN'S KILLING
MACHINE.
THIS ALL EXPLAINS WHY MORE THAN
3 MILLION REFUGEES HAVE FLED TO
PARTS OF EUROPE, AN ASTONISHING
NUMBER.
ONE REFUGEE LEFT THIS MESSAGE ON
A SIGN, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THE CARE.
ALL PEOPLE WERE NICE TO US AND
WE NEVER FELT HUNGRY, COLD OR
LONELY.
THANK YOU.
SINCE THE WAR BEGAN WE HAVE
TRIED TO FIND RAYS OF LIGHT IN
THE DARKNESS.
A BRAVE RUSSIAN JOURNALIST RAN
ON TO THE SET OF A STATE TV
PROGRAM TO PROTEST THE WAR.
SHE TOLD CNN WHY SHE DID IT.
>> Translator: I'M WATCHING MY
ELDERLY MOM WHO WATCHES AND
LISTENS TO THIS PROPAGANDA FROM
MORNING TO NIGHT, AND SHE'S SO
BRAINWASHED, THAT I CAN'T TALK
TO HER FOR FIVE MINUTES BECAUSE
THESE PHRASES SHE KEEPS
REPEATING -- THE PHRASES SHE
HEARS ON TV.
>> "I'M WATCHING MY ELDERLY MOM
WHO WATCHES AND LISTENS TO THIS
PROPAGANDA FROM MORNING TO NIGHT
AND SHE IS SO BRAINWASHED," THAT
JOURNALIST SAID OF HER MOTHER.
YES, A CRITICAL PART OF PUGH
TEN'S ATTACKS ON THE UKRAINIAN
PEOPLE IS HIS ASSAULT ON THE
TRUTH, HIS DERANGED ALTERNATE
REALITY WAS ON FULL DISPLAY LATE
LAST WEEK AS HE STAGED THIS
MASSIVE PRO-WAR RALLY.
THE RUSSIAN LEADER BRAGGED THAT
EVERYTHING IS GOING ACCORDING TO
PLAN, EVEN THOUGH WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS SAY
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
HAVE BEEN KILLED IN UKRAINE.
AND HE LIED ABOUT HIS RATIONALE
FOR THE WAR WITH AN ABSURD CLAIM
THAT HE IS TRYING TO STOP
GENOCIDE.
>> Translator: TO FREE THE
PEOPLE FROM SUFFERING AND THIS
GENOCIDE IS OUR MAIN INITIATING
REASON AND GOAL FOR RUSSIA
STARTING THE SPECIAL OPERATION
IN DONBAS AND UKRAINE.
>> SOME RUSSIANS TOLD CNN THEY
WERE FORCED TO ATTEND THE RALLY,
JUST ONE OF MANY CHILLING SIGNS
RUSSIANS ARE BEING WARNED TO
SWALLOW PUTIN'S LIES.
PUTIN IS THREATENING PRISON TIME
FOR PEOPLE WHO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THE WAR AND IS TALKING ABOUT A
SELF-CLEANSING OF RUSSIAN
SOCIETY.
>> Translator: ANY PEOPLE, THE
RUSSIAN PEOPLE ESPECIALLY, ARE
ABLE TO DISTINGUISH TRUE
PATRIOTS FROM BASTARDS AND
TRAITORS AND WILL SPIT THEM OUT
LIKE A GNAT THAT ACCIDENTALLY
FLEW INTO THEIR MOUTHS.
I AM CERTAIN THAT THIS NECESSARY
AND NATURAL SELF-CLEANING OF OUR
SOCIETY WILL ONLY STRENGTHEN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> LIES HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A PART
OF PUTIN'S PLAYBOOK IN UKRAINE.
BACK IN 2014 WHEN RUSSIA FIRST
INVADED UKRAINE AND CRIMEA,
PUTIN INITIALLY DENIED RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS WERE BEHIND THE ATTACK
UNTIL HE LATER SAID, OF COURSE,
THEY WERE FROM HIS COUNTRY.
IN HIS LATEST ASSAULT ON UKRAINE
PUTIN TOLD THE LIE HIS TROOPS
WERE HEADING OFF TO FIGHT THE
NAZIS.
THEN THE RUSSIANS BEGAN TO MAKE
THE BOGUS CLAIM THERE WERE
U.S.-BACKED BIOLABS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF THAT.
YET SOME ON THE FAR RIGHT, HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES, HAVE
AMPLIFIED THESE LIES SO
EFFECTIVELY ECHOING PUTIN'S
PROPAGANDA THAT THEY ARE SHOWN
REGULARLY ON RUSSIAN STATE
TELEVISION.
THE QUESTION HAS TO BE ASKED HOW
COULD ANYBODY IN THIS COUNTRY OR
ANYWHERE AROUND THE WORLD DEFEND
OR EVEN TRY TO EXPLAIN WHAT
PUTIN IS DOING?
WHAT PUTIN IS DOING IS EVIL.
THE DEVASTATION AND THE CARNAGE
AND THE STAMPEDE OF HUMAN BEINGS
OUT OF UKRAINE IS ALL CAUSED BY
ONE MAN.
FOR THE BETTER PART OF THE LAST
TWO DECADES, PUTIN HAS GOTTEN
AWAY WITH MURDER AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
HE HAS POISONED MORE THAN JUST
HIS OPPOSITION IN RUSSIA.
PUTIN HAS POISONED OUR WORLD
WITH VIOLENCE AND LIES.
AND FOR THE TRUTH TO HAVE A
FIGHTING CHANCE IN UKRAINE AND,
YES,